donc je recherche plus tous trois pièces
avec une salle de réunion sur la
circonscription la troisième elle n'a
que quelques jours pour préparer sa
nouvelle vie choisir ses collaborateurs
est installé sa permanence parlementaire
c'est important je crois d'avoir aussi
des bonnes conditions de travail pour
mes collaborateurs et moi même ces
locaux aussi devront demain accueillir
les concitoyens et concitoyennes hier
soir fadila khattabi a été élu dans la
troisième circonscription de côte-d'or
désormais député elle doit abandonner
son métier
je ne pourrais pas quand même assurer
les trois dernières semaines de cours
parce que je t'ai absolument être une
députée à temps plein après 25 ans à
enseigner l'anglais au cfaa de longvic
c'est une page qui se tourne
je suis député voilages essaye quand
même de réaliser parce que c'est quand
même voilà et je mesure surtout toutes
les responsabilités qui pèse un peu sur
mes épaules quoi parce que nous n'avons
pas le droit à l'erreur
ce gouvernement n'a pas le droit à
l'erreur il ya vraiment une attente
considérable
on a suscité de l'espoir maintenant à
nous de répondre aux attentes des
français
je vous remercie on a fait campagne une
campagne vraiment très intense
à 55 ans est proche de françois patriat
a déjà été vice présidente socialiste du
conseil régional en charge de la
formation pendant dix ans mais c'est son
premier mandat parlementaire c'est un
défi mais j'ai la chance quand même
d'avoir une expérience d'élu et ça va me
servir quand même donc à la fois bon
j'ai une petite appréhension mais en
même temps je suis pressée d'agir d'être
dans l'action
je suis une femme d'action donc voilà
donc j'ai hâte
j'ai hâte d'y être première visite à
l'assemblée nationale dès demain 1er
séminaire de travail ce week end
l'agenda s'annonce chargée pour la
nouvelle élue